hey everybody mr kobe here and
we're gonna do a little experiment here
i've got five
glass flasks actually one of them is
plastic but still
five flasks and um
you can see flask number one 50
milliliters of warm water
and i'm going to add two grams of
baker's yeast
mix it all up flask number two
is going to be 50 milliliters of warm
water i'm going to add 2 grams of yeast
and i'm going to add
1 gram of sugar mix it all up
flask number 3 50 milliliters of warm
water
i'm gonna add two grams of yeast and
three grams of sugar mix it all up
flask number four 50 milliliters of
really hot water
boiling hot to uh two grams of yeast
and one gram of sugar mix it all up
and flask number five fifty milliliters
of coal there's still ice crystals in it
that's how cold it is
fifty milliliters of cold water two
grams of yeast
and one gram of sugar so i'm gonna set
the camera down
and i'm gonna go ahead and mix all of
these
and then i'll be right back
okay now that i went ahead and mixed all
of those together notice that there's a
balloon
next to each flask in a moment i'm going
to put the camera down
and i'm going to attach the balloon to
the top
of the flask so the balloon will capture
any gases that are given off by the
yeast
in this particular process so i'm going
to go ahead and stop
filming i'm not going to be able to put
the balloons on while i'm filming
i'm going to stop filming and i'll come
back and let you see what i've done
okay so i've gone ahead and i've
attached a balloon
to each of the five flasks
and again there's yeast inside
and the yeast inside might give off a
gas throughout this process and if so
the gas should accumulate
inside of the flask and
we'll see what happens to the balloons
over the course of some time
while i sit here and wait so just to
give you an idea of where we are
the flasks are sealed so no gas can
escape
and we're going to go ahead i'm going to
go ahead and stop filming
and i'll come back in a little bit to
show you some of the results
okay everybody so it's actually been
about an hour
um since we started and you can see
that flask number one was given two
grams of yeast
zero sugar fifty milliliters of warm
water and you can see that the
balloon did not inflate at all
flask number two was given two grams of
yeast
one gram of sugar and fifty milliliters
of warm
water and you can see wow look at that
bubble of the balloon has inflated
you can see that flask number three was
given two grams of yeast
three grams of sugar and 50 ml 50
milliliters of warm water
and you can see that yes the balloon has
inflated
flask number four was given two grams
of yeast one gram of sugar and 50
milliliters of boiling boiling
hot water after an hour the water is not
hot anymore but at the time was boiling
hot
and you can see the balloon did not
inflate
flask number five was given two grams
of yeast one gram of sugar 50
milliliters of cold water
and again you can see that the balloon
has not inflated
now let me go back to flask two and
three
they were both given warm water sorry i
forgot to add the word
warm right here but they were both given
warm
water and if you notice the setup
they're the same
except for flask two was given one gram
of sugar
flask three was given three grams of
sugar let's
look at the balloon comparison they both
have balloons that inflated and i'm not
sure if you can tell the difference
but the one uh the green one the one on
the right flask number three
it's actually a little more inflated
than the red one on the left
what i'm going to do in a moment i'm
going to
put down the camera and i'm going to
take a string
and i'm going to just kind of wrap the
string around each balloon
and then i can measure the circumference
of the balloon by measuring the length
of the string so
if that doesn't make sense i'll show you
what i mean in a moment but i need both
my hands to do this
i'm going to just wrap a little string
around the green balloon
and then measure the length of the
string and i'm going to wrap
a string around the red balloon and
again measure the length of this
of the string that'll give me the
circumference of
the balloon so i'm going to stop i'll be
right back
okay and so here you can see the results
these two pieces of string i wrapped
around
one on top i wrapped around the red
balloon and one on the bottom
i wrapped around the green balloon so
the one on top was flask number two
and when you pull the string tight it
comes to a circumference
of about 22 centimeters so again i
wrapped the string around the balloon
and then i measured the length of the
string and it was about 22 centimeters
all the way around now
for flask number three that was the
bottom piece of string
when you pull it tight it comes to about
26
centimeters 26 centimeters so again
that string i wrapped around the entire
balloon
and then i measured the length of the
string
and has a circumference the balloon has
a circumference of about 26 centimeters
so that allows me to quantify my data
i can actually have a quantity now a
numerical value that i can measure
okay so based on not only the
observations
of how much the balloons inflated but
also the measurements that you now have
again with flask number one there's
nothing to measure so uh
zero would be our circumference of the
balloon there's nothing to measure
same with flask number four and flask
number five there's there's nothing to
measure really
so the measurements really are in flask
number two in flask
number three all right so we're going to
go ahead and finish the rest of this
activity you can probably answer the
questions
in your lab handout now